durchgeführt wird der wähler ihnen eine
einschätzung geben
zur situation und die neuesten zahlen
vorstellen und danach wenn wir die
eingeschickten fragen in der auswahl
beantworten
na bitte guten morgen hier im hörsaal
morgen den zuhörern draußen und
zuschauern zunächst eine kurze
lage-einschätzung das heißt er die
vermeldung der zahlen die offiziell
gemeldet wurden
sowie 19 fallzahlen weltweit und in
europa ohne deutschland datenstand
vierundzwanzigster dritter 2020 10 uhr
weltweit ohne deutschland wie gesagt
wurden offiziell 348 1829 fälle gemeldet
das ist zum vortrag eine differenz von
35.000 300 und der anteil der
verstorbenen liegt bei insgesamt 4,7
prozent der europäische wirtschaftsraum
und die eu haben wir 153 1258 fälle das
sind mehr als 17.000 1799 mehr als am
vortag
hier liegt der anteil der verstorbenen
an den offiziell gemeldeten fällen bei
65 prozent
das ist derart datenstand den wir vom
europäischen center für disease control
gemeldet bekommen haben und 24
um 10 uhr
die länder mit den höchsten fallzahlen
ebenfalls datenstand 24 der dritter 2020
10 uhr
italien in italien wurden bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt offiziell gemeldet 63 1927
fälle das sind 4 1789 mehr als am vortag
und in italien liegt der anteil der
verstorbenen unter diesen offiziell
gemeldeten fällen bei 95 prozent
in spanien haben wir zu diesem zeitpunkt
33.000 89 fälle gemeldet
das ist zum vortag eine erhöhung um
4.500 17 fälle und in spanien liegt der
anteil der verstorbenen an den offiziell
gemeldeten fällen bei 6,6 prozent
auch außerhalb europas neben die zahlen
zu china ist bei dieser betrachtung
jetzt nicht erfasst
die vereinigten staaten hatten zu diesem
zeitpunkt 46 1442 fälle gemeldet das ist
eine zunahme zum vortag um 11.000 236
und dort liegt der anteil der
verstorbenen unter den melde fällen bei
1,3 prozent
als letztes beispiel noch den iran
gemeldet die offiziellen meldezahlen
waren dort gestern um 10 uhr bei 23.000
49 waren gegenüber dem vortag 1411 mehr
dort liegt die sterberate der offiziell
gemeldeten bei 7,9 prozent
wie sieht die situation in deutschland
aus und ich möchte wieder betonen das
ist die situation die auf offiziellen
meldezahlen beruht nicht auf schätzungen
oder hochrechnungen sondern auf
offiziellen meldezahlen diese
meldezahlen beinhalten ja nicht nur die
reinen zahlen sondern auch
epidemiologische daten zu den fällen die
natürlich sehr wichtig sind
in deutschland wurden bis heute also 25
dritter 2020 00 uhr ein und für 31.000 5
154 kw 19 fälle gemeldet das ist eine
zunahme gegenüber dem vortag von 4.100
18 fällen das sind fälle die über die
gesundheitsämter elektronisch mit dem
meldesystem nach gesetzlicher vorgabe
dem robert koch institut übermittelt
wurden darunter waren 149 todesfälle
das sind 35 mehr als am tag davor die
gesamtzahl die gesamt incidence beträgt
momentan in deutschland 38 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner also wie erwartet
nimmt diese zahl zu wir stehen am anfang
dieser epidemie und die zahl nimmt zu
aber wie auch in den letzten tagen und
wie es auch in der zukunft nach unserer
einschätzung sein wird variiert diese
zahl von bundesland zu bundesland im
deutschlandweit ein beispiel in hamburg
haben wir 69 fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
in bayern haben wir zurzeit 50 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner offiziell nach
gesetzlichen vorgaben gemeldete fälle
in mecklenburg vorpommern sind es nur 14
fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
nach unseren schätzungen waren zu diesem
zeitpunkt mindestens 5600 infizierte
chinesen
das heißt also die zahl der genesenen
nimmt natürlich ebenfalls zu nach
unserer schätzung 5600 mindestens die
betroffene person die infiziert sind in
deutschland sind im durchschnitt 45
jahre alt und die verstorbenen personen
waren im durchschnitt 81 jahre alt
datenstand 25 10 30 uhr männer 55
prozent häufiger betroffen als frauen 45
prozent für 22.000 581 der übermittelten
fälle liegen und klinische informationen
vor
da hat sich eigentlich nichts geändert
husten 54% fieber 40 prozent wir werden
oder dass das ist der lagebericht also
die nüchternen fakten und wir berufen
uns auf offizielle meldezahlen nicht auf
hochrechnungen sondern auch offizielle
meldezahlen das ist etwa so als wenn sie
ein amtliches ergebnis haben wollen das
ist eben genauer und dafür braucht es
ein wenig länger
wie kommen die fallzahlen bei den
neuinfektionen zustande
ich möchte nochmal hier ihnen erklären
wie diese zahlen zu uns kommen und warum
wir auf diese art liche zahlen wert
legen wenn das örtliche gesundheitsamt
über einen neuen fall informiert wird
muss dieser fall spätestens am nächsten
arbeitstag elektronisch an die
zuständigen landesbehörden und von dort
an das robert koch institut übermittelt
werden
dafür gibt es eine gesetzliche
vorschrift das ist das
infektionsschutzgesetz wir sehen aktuell
aber tatsächlich dass viele
gesundheitsämter sogar schneller sind
und sogar am gleichen tag übermitteln
viele gesundheitsämter übermitteln auch
am wochenende aber natürlich nicht alle
nicht jeder wird wie die etwa 150
mitarbeiter im robert-koch-institut die
seit acht wochen in zwei schichten
sieben tage die woche arbeiten das wird
nicht jeder tun und das kann ich auch
gut verstehen und das ist auch mein
mitarbeitern nicht ewig zumutbar
durch diese übermittlung gibt es
natürlich immer wieder einen gewissen
verzug
natürlich gibt es auch manchmal
technische probleme im system
dann kann es sein dass das
robert-koch-institut diese daten etwas
später erhalt durch diesen melden verzug
sind die daten der letzten tage oft noch
nicht ganz vollständig sie werden aber
dann natürlich im laufe der darauf
folgenden tage ergänzt
sie sehen an unseren meldedaten dass
weiter viele fälle gemeldet werden die
fälle nehmen zu auch tagesschwankungen
sind natürlich zu erhalten wir müssen
weiter abwarten um zu sehen ob die
maßnahmen greifen
aber im moment ist es zu früh um diese
aussagen schon belastbar treffen zu
können
ich werde oft gefragt warum wir in
deutschland im vergleich zu manchen
ländern geringe sterberaten unter den
fellen sehen wir wissen nicht genau
warum das der fall ist
aber wir denken dass hier einige
faktoren zustande dass einige faktoren
dafür dem dem zugrunde liegen zunächst
mal ganz klar gesagt das ist keine
untererfassung in deutschland wurde von
anfang an vergleichsweise breit getestet
deshalb haben wir den erreger früh
entdeckt und wir entdecken auch viele
milde fälle dadurch die man sonst
vielleicht nicht gefunden hätte sie
sehen das unter anderem daran dass bei
den klinischen symptome 50 prozent mehr
als 50 prozent touristen haben und rund
40% fieber das heißt also wir erfassen
auch viele leichte fehler
außerdem sind in deutschland bislang
noch nicht so viele alte menschen
erkrankt
das ist auch ein fakt der sich in den
todeszahlen und dem alter schwankungen
darstellt und ich möchte noch mal
betonen wie ich das schon seit langer
zeit tue
wir sind am anfang der epidemie es ist
noch völlig offen wie sich diese
epidemie weiter entwickelt und natürlich
steigt auch in deutschland die anzahl
der todesfälle
weiterhin haben wir die fall
definitionen und das fluss schema
angepasst auch das nochmal zur klarheit
seit wochen vermittle ich ihnen dass wir
systematisch daran gehen diese epidemie
eindämmen zu wollen und wir passen
natürlich unsere maßnahmen immer wieder
den epidemiologischen gegebenheiten an
und wir können natürlich auch nicht
außer acht lassen was in der welt um uns
herum geschieht es ist ja eine pandemie
und darum haben wir die kriterien
angepasst nach denen ärzte entscheiden
sollen welche patienten auf kurven 19
getestet werden soll
prinzipiell gilt prinzipiell dass nur
menschen getestet werden die symptome
zahlen
hier gibt es ein paar ausschlaggebende
kriterien hatten sie kontakt mit einem
bestätigten kurve 19 fall gehören sie zu
einer risikogruppe
oder gehören sie zum medizinischen
personal oder wenn die menschen schwer
krank sind haben wir keine andere die
katze also keine differentialdiagnose
das sind alles entscheidung die der arzt
vor ort zu treffen hat eine
entscheidende änderung ist die dass das
bisherige kriterium dass die patienten
in einem gebiet mit kurven 19 fällen
gewesen sein müssen entfällt warum ist
das so
der erreger breitet sich immer weiter
aus es ist eine pandemie und es macht
dann irgendwann keinen sinn mehr nach
einzelnen gebieten zu unterscheiden
das hatte ich bereits mehrfach erwähnt
dass wir das immer anpassen werden und
wir schauen wie wir mit den
risikogebieten in der zukunft umgehen
es ist nur ein überblick für die zuhörer
und diejenigen die hier im hörsaal sind
aber den ärzten haben wir am schluss
schema im internet dazu zur verfügung
gestellt dass alle ärzte kennen sollten
und auch sicher kennen und dass wir
kontinuierlich um die letzten wochen
angepasst haben wir gehen davon aus dass
diese änderung dabei helfen werden die
ressourcen für tests gezielter
einzusetzen dass ärzte einfach besser
priorisieren können denn natürlich haben
wir nicht so viele tests dass man die
einfach sinnlos einsetzen kann sondern
wir müssen gezielt strategisch sinnvoll
gezielt diese tests einsetzen
das bindet sonst nur unnötig
laborkapazitäten und patienten die milde
erkrankten und aktuell nicht getestet
werden können weil zu wenig kapazitäten
zur verfügung stehen
sie sollten bitte einfach zu hause
bleiben und kontakt zu anderen meiden
also abstand halten ich möchte dann auch
noch ein paar worte sagen zu jüngeren
erkrankten wir wissen etwas was wir
schon lange wissen wir wissen ja vieles
über die krankheit nicht aber etwas was
wir schon lange wissen ist dass das
risiko ernsthaft an kurven sind zu
erkrankten schwere verläufe zu erleben
oder sogar daran zu sterben mit dem
steigen von risikofaktoren und mit dem
steigenden alter zunimmt
aber ich betone dass auch immer wieder
auch jüngere und gesunde menschen können
sehr schwer an kurven 19 erkranken halt
nur mit einer geringeren häufigkeit es
gibt auch jüngere menschen und gesunde
menschen die an kurven 19 sterben können
das passiert selten nach allem was wir
bislang wissen aber es kann eben
passieren und das wissen wir zum
beispiel aus unseren nachbarländern und
es muss ihnen auch allen klar sein je
mehr menschen in deutschland erkranken
desto wahrscheinlicher wird es natürlich
auch sein dass darunter auch solche
fälle sind bei jüngeren mitmenschen
ich würde mal ganz klar sagen wir haben
gerade erst damit begonnen corona zu
bekämpfen
wir müssen alle diszipliniert das tun
was wir seit wochen fordern
und ich sage auch noch mal dass wir
selber viele sind der hand haben jeder
mitmensch jeder bürger kann etwas gegen
die ausbreitung der epidemie tun nämlich
dazu beitragen dass das virus sich nicht
von einem menschen auf den anderen
überträgt wie tun wir das die
bekämpfungsstrategie des
robert-koch-instituts ruht auf drei
säulen eindämmung cupid 19 fälle müssen
schnell identifiziert werden und
isoliert werden die kontakte müssen
nachverfolgt und unter quarantäne
gestellt werden dafür müssten gezielt
getestet werden dafür müssen die
gesundheitsämter maximale unterstützung
erfahren
zweite säule schutz der wohlhabenden
gruppen also jeder menschen die alt hoch
altrich sind und chronischen
grundkrankheiten haben dritte säule die
kapazitäten im gesundheitssystem erhöhen
das gilt sowohl für die test kapazität
auch die müssen wir kontinuierlich
weiter erhöhen
als natürlich auch die kapazitäten in
den kliniken wo die patienten dann
behandelt werden darum meine
aufforderung die intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte in die kliniken zu
verdoppeln
und ich weiß auch dass schon viele
kliniken das getan haben und das ist gut
so
das ist richtig so und das ist wichtig
so und wir versuchen auch verschiedene
möglichkeiten um den zuweisung von
patienten zu kliniken zu koordinieren
unser gesundheitssystem ist nicht in dem
maße digitalisiert wie sich das viele
wünschen das wäre dann einfacher aber
wir versuchen so viel wie möglich zu
machen wie es geht und das wird dazu
helfen bestimmt viele menschenleben zu
retten
aber ich sage es nochmal wir alle müssen
dazu beitragen abstand halten
wenn man krank ist zu hause bleiben und
dann werden wir nach besten
möglichkeiten mit dieser epidemie
umgehen die unser gesundheitssystem
sicher stressen wird und die noch einige
wochen ins land sein
dann ging ja vielen dank herr wieder ich
es kommt jetzt eine auswahl der anfragen
die uns bis 8 uhr geschickt worden sind
wir bin schon mal vorab um verständnis
dass wir nicht alle berücksichtigen
können wir bekommen insgesamt sehr sehr
viele anfragen und wir haben bis
halbzeit und deswegen die bitte jeweils
um kurze antwort die welt fragt wie
stark muss die zahl der täglichen
neuinfektionen zurückgehen dass sie der
bundesregierung mit gutem gewissen
empfehlen können die maßnahmen wieder zu
lockern kann ich keine definitiven
antwort geben wir schauen uns das
ständig an
wir müssen auch sehen wie die maßnahmen
wirken dazu kann ich keine aussage
treffen das ist ein geschehen für die es
keine blaupause gibt wir schauen uns
täglich die entwicklung an und
entscheiden dpa fragt um die unbedingt
ausbreitung modellen entscheiden zu
können wann man welche maßnahmen
zumindest zeitweise wieder zurück fährt
ist das essenziell die dunkelziffer im
land den einzelnen regionen und in den
einzelnen regierungen möglichst gut
abschätzen zu können was für ansätze
gibt es da für diese dunkelziffer
schätzen zu können ja das ist natürlich
nicht trivial zu dem man ja auch auf
jede zahl festgelegt wird es gibt
berechnungen dazu modellierungen wir
tauschen uns hier auch mit befreundeten
institutionen in anderen ländern aus die
dunkelziffer zu berichten ist aber nicht
einfach weil in jedem land auch
unterschiedliche test strategien da sind
sobald für eine einschätzung dazu haben
und uns mit genügend statistiken und
modellieren trauen etwas zu sagen werden
wir das vermelden aber momentan kann ich
das nicht tun
noch eine frage von dpa china meldet
seit tagen keine neuinfektionen mehr
macht ihnen das hoffnung auch für
deutschland das virus in einigen wochen
eingedämmt zu haben
also natürlich bin ich optimistisch dass
unsere maßnahmen helfen aber ich möchte
noch einmal betonen dass in china ein
massiver lockdown stattgefunden hat mit
wirklich großen sozialen verwerfungen
und deshalb möchte ich die situation in
deutschland mit der in china nicht
vergleichen
das handelsblatt fragt berichte aus
china hatten es gerade besagen dass der
entscheidende faktor für den erfolg
gehen wo haben die zentralisierte
quarantäne sei bei der infizierte sehr
schnell von der familie getrennt wurden
weil die meisten ansteckungen in den
familien passieren
in italien soll das auch eingeführt
werden wie bewerten sie das und ist das
für deutschland sinnvoll
mir ist nicht bekannt ob das in italien
auch eingeführt werden soll das weiß ich
nicht hab gestern gerade erst mit dem
italienischen kollegen gesprochen der
das leitet aber ich muss noch mal sehr
deutlich sagen wir müssen abstand halten
das ist wichtig und wenn man abstand
hält ein meter fünfzig mindestens zwei
meter dann ist es natürlich auch in
einer familie möglich dass man sich
nicht ansteckt bislang sehe ich keinen
anlass dazu zu dieser maßnahme zu raten
aber noch mal es gibt kein patentrezept
es gibt keine blaupause wir werden uns
das alles anschauen und immer wieder die
maßnahmen anpassen
dpa audio fragt inwieweit spielt das
wetter eine rolle bei der ausbreitung
des virus verhindert eine trockene kälte
er die ausbreitung
wir wissen noch nicht so viel über das
virus um das einwandfreie sagen zu
können wir sehen aber das ja eigentlich
überall auf der welt in allen ländern
sich das virus ausbreitet insofern ist
der einfluss des klimas oder das wetter
da haben wir bisher noch nicht wirklich
belastbare aussagen um last zu sehen wir
gehen auf jeden fall davon aus dass wenn
es wärmer ist und die sonne intensiv
scheint dass das virus dann insgesamt in
der umwelt nicht mehr so also schlechter
überleben können aber mehr können wir zu
diesen einflussfaktoren bislang nicht
sagen
der wdr fragt gibt es daten wie oft die
atemnot sehr schnell eintritt also wie
bald sollte man ins krankenhaus wenn man
ein risikopatient ist und den verdacht
hat sich angesteckt zu haben aber es
geht noch nicht schlecht ja das sind
natürlich entscheidung die der arzt zu
fällen hat klar ist wenn man atemnot hat
also im vergleich zum normalen leben
wenn die atmo zunimmt dann muss man
natürlich einen arzt konsultieren
schade dass wir in deutschland nicht
mehr telemedizin haben dann wäre das
deutlich leichter aber hier geht es halt
darum dass die das wirklich die die die
patienten mit ihren zuständigen
hausärzten in einem guten kontakt sind
rtl aktuell n-tv fragt wie hat die
bundesregierung den vom rk ii
federführend entwickelten und 2013
vorgestellten pandemieplan aufgenommen
denn darin ging es auch schon um den
engpass medizinische güter und es gab
klare anweisungen zur schul geschäfts
und grenzschließung wurde das umgesetzt
na ja zunächst mal sind die
pandemiepläne ja in den ländern der in
den händen der länder und der lokalen
behörden umzusetzen
wie gut dass ein einzelfall umgesetzt
wurde oder nicht kann ich nicht
beurteilen
der bericht wurde sehr positiv
aufgenommen damals weil natürlich sehr
viele maßnahmen die durch drin empfohlen
wurden als sinnvoll erachtet werden und
wir werden im laufe der zeit sehen wie
gut die ein oder andere maßnahme
umgesetzt wurde wie gut zum beispiel
ärzte sich auch darauf vorbereitet haben
das ist eine epidemie mit einem wirklich
sehr sehr großem ausmaß und es kann
sicher niemanden geben der zu 100% auf
eine solche große aufgabe optimal
vorbereitet wilden sein wird dpa hat
eine frage geschickt in den usa in
italien sollen cupid 19 patienten mit
antikörpern von genesenen patienten
behandelt werden ist das ein
vielversprechender ansatz in studien
dazu auch in deutschland vorgesehen
ja das ist ein ansatz der auch in
deutschland unternommen wird da müsste
das paul ehrlich institut sprach fähig
sein ich weiß dass solche studien auch
in deutschland laufen
aber wie viele wie intensiv das ist wie
viele patienten involviert sind dazu
kann ich keine aussage machen auf jeden
fall ist das ein sinnvoller
gedanke wir müssen in dieser krise
wirklich alle konzepte ausprobieren die
wir als sinnhaft erachten
hier wird es viele viele verschiedene
konzepte geben auch bezüglich klinischer
studien mit medikamenten müssen wir uns
gut koordinieren
wichtig ist natürlich dass das
koordiniert läuft nach nach festen
schema k und übertragbar ist und solche
untersuchungen laufen natürlich auch in
anderen ländern und die ist auch wichtig
dass wir diese informationen austauschen
und das ist diese koordinierung und und
die transparente information ist hier
einer der wichtigsten schlüssel zum
erfolg dann wird noch gefragt wann es in
deutschland der einsatz von schnelltests
erwartbar gute frage
es gibt schon einige schnelltests die
qualität der schnelltests die mir
bekannt sind ist aber noch nicht so
hinreichend ich muss aber sagen das ist
auch in dem fall dass beh farm und das
paul ehrlich institut die diese
testungen ja teilweise zu lassen
zumindest bewerten wie gut die tests
sind und sie können nur sicher sein dass
solche tests nötig sind wir brauchen
viele von den tests wir müssen die test
kapazitäten hochfahren aber das
schlimmste was wir tun könnten wäre
natürlich tests anzuwenden
die qualitativ schlecht sind weil sie
uns natürlich falschen daten geben wir
brauchen diese tests wir brauchen diese
tests zum nachweis des virus um die
kapazitäten hochzufahren
und wir brauchen natürlich auf dauer
tests wo wir antikörper nachweise und
haben um zu sehen ob manche menschen
schon immun sind gegen das virus
und auch das ist ein wichtiger punkt um
die dunkelziffer zum beispiel zu
berechnen wenn wir in repräsentativen
stichproben die übrigens auch geplant
sind bereits aber auch noch nicht
gefangen auch an demnächst dauert
natürlich alles seine zeit wir können
das wir seit kurzer zeit den krankheit
erst seit wenigen wochen dass wir dann
über diese tests auch erfahren wie die
dunkelziffer der krankheit ist die ard
tagesschau fragt die von ihnen
veröffentlichten corona fallzahlen für
deutschland hinten regelmäßig denen
anderer seriöser quellen hinterher
warum ist das gesundheitsämtern oder
landesbehörden nicht
mögliche positive testergebnisse
schneller elektronisch zu übermitteln
was spricht dagegen ihre datenerhebungen
anzupassen um die veröffentlichung von
fallzahlen zu beschleunigen
also es spricht nichts dagegen die die
fallzahlen schneller zu haben aber ich
habe ihn gerade erklärt wie der meldeweg
ist und ich vergleiche das mal so es
gibt hochrechnungen
das kennen sie glaube ich auch von
wahlabenden und von vielen erhalten und
es gibt eben amtlich festgestellten
ergebnisse und wir wollen ihnen und wir
werden auch weiterhin ihnen die amtlich
festgestellten ergebnisse vermitteln ja
es ganz klar warum ist das so dass ich
kann verstehen dass viele auf die zahlen
schauen und diese zahlen sind bestimmt
auch nicht falsch aber diese zahlen sind
eben noch eine dankte zahlen ohne
hintergrundinformationen und durch die
meldungen mit dir über die gesundheits-
und erhalten wir natürlich wichtige
informationen über die patienten über
die altersstruktur der patienten über
das geschlecht der patienten das
infektionsschutzgesetz lässt nicht so
viele informationen zu wie sie wie ich
sie gerne hätte dann könnte ich mag ihre
fragen auch besser beantworten aber das
ist normal in deutschland sei aber
wichtig ist wirklich das entscheidende
ist dass wir wissen dass es melde
vorzüge gibt das wir wissen wann eine
meldung erfolgt wurde ein patient früh
gemeldet im krankheitsverlauf oder spät
gemeldet das können wir den daten ja
alle ansehen
das sehen sie den daten die
hochgerechnet sind natürlich nicht an
weil auch die datenquellen
unterschiedliche qualitäten
darum haben wir diese daten immer im
auge keine frage
ja wir wissen die daten von anderen die
zur verfügung gestellt werden wir wir
nehmen sie natürlich in unsere
überlegung mit hinein
aber wir werden ihnen immer das amtliche
endergebnis melden
die zeitschrift der hausarzt fragt von
verschiedenen seiten wird gefordert die
test strategie zu wechseln und sich mehr
auf risikopersonen patienten bei denen
sich der zustand verschlechtert sowie
gesundheitsberufe zu fokussieren hält
das lka einen solchen wechsel für
sinnvoll
ja das ist sicher ein missverständnis es
ist auch nicht für jeden einfach zu
verstehen
die strategie die wir den ärzten schon
seit wochen auferlegen oder die
empfehlung die wir
gegeben sind ja nur empfehlungen die wir
den ärzten geben ich habe ihnen gerade
vorgelesen was die kriterien sind nach
denen ärzte testen sollen die kriterien
haben sich im wesentlichen nicht
verändert ein wesentlicher grund
änderung ist er mit den risikogebieten
weil eben deutschland hier inzwischen
selber eine epidemie hat und damit
selber ein gebiet ist in dem es ein
risiko vorliegt
es war immer unser anliegen dass
systematisch getestet wird
weil wir dann natürlich viel bessere
aussagen haben über unsere schätzungen
und das ist sehr sehr wichtig betont
nochmal das ist einer der gründe nach
wie vor werden sicher immer noch zu
viele symptomlose getestet das der grund
warum wir auch diese zahlen haben die
ich ihn vorgestellt habe ich wünsche
dass tests wirklich systematisch
koordiniert ein getestet eingesetzt
werden aber wir haben nun mal ein
gesundheitssystem der sehr
diversifiziert ist und alle die
informationen die ich gerne hätte
die sind es schwer zu bekommen wird
unser gesundheitswesen eben nicht in dem
maße digitalisiert ist wie es ist dann
könnten wir patienten noch leichter zu
führen wenn jeder patient eine
elektronische patientenakte hätte dann
wäre viele viel steuerung der patienten
definitiv einfacher und auch wir hätten
bessere informationslage dpa audi hat
noch gefragt in südkorea tragen viele
menschen gesichts maß genommen andere
nicht anzustecken viele geschäfte haben
geöffnet warum wird diese
flächendeckende schutzmaßnahmen nicht in
deutschland erfolgen ja wir haben ja
immer empfohlen und das tun wir
weiterhin menschen die erkrankt sind
mögen eine maske tragen weil sie in
einem daneben diese tröpfchen infektion
unter bin also noch mal das virus wird
hauptsächlich der wichtigste
übertragungsweg tröpfchen husten niesen
darum bitten wir sie immer oder fordern
sie auf dass sie durch entsprechende
hygienemaßnahmen halten händewaschen in
die armbeuge niesen husten
wenn sie erkrankt sind und eine maske
tragen einen mund nasen schutz tragen
ist klar dass diese top finde ich so
weit fliegen darum ist es wichtig dass
erkrankte diese masken tragen und
beziehungsweise muten nasenschutz tragen
das ist klar
eine weitere gruppe die unbedingt diese
mund nasenschutz oder auch masken tragen
sollen sind natürlich diejenigen die die
kranken behandeln da sind also in erster
linie medizinisches fachpersonal und
ärzte die müssen geschützt werden und
wenn wenn diese gruppen entsprechend
masken tragen dann dann ist das eine
sehr wirksame wirkungsvolle maßnahme die
nach heutigen wissenschaftlichen wissen
auch angebracht ist und durchgeführt
werden sollte dann bedanken wir uns ganz
herzlich für ihre fragen bitten auch was
zukünftige fragen betrifft wirklich auch
auf der internetseite nachzuschauen
wir schaffen es tatsächlich im moment
auch nicht mehr alle presseanfragen zu
beantworten das sind einfach viel zu
viele und wir sehen uns freitag wieder
vielen dank viele schon
[Applaus]